Brent's got his package Brent at the
radio Hall of Fame he's very passionate
about the Hall of Fame a spokesperson so
you you're really into radial Hall of
Fame I am I am I think
agreed but I think it should have the
same level or respect with the Rock and
Roll Hall of Fame at I think his next
project is he wants Fred to get in I
want Fred in and Gary in and the Howard
Stern Show I want Fred in I want Fred
out of here in the radio right seriously
you should be in the Hall of Fame humble
look how unique what the unique thing
that Fred does nobody else in radio does
what go ahead
what do again just no one wants it so
remind people with Rizzo well he got me
I mean he adds a layer to this show
that's really incredible sound effects I
love him Fred should be in the radio
Hall of Fame 100% yeah I like airy play
clip 18 JD because there's a personality
and he speaks well on the air he's been
a great answer for a lot of years
someone took interesting stores for the
show you don't have to convince me
I'll tell you about the time when I was
very young and I actually was going to
maybe going to the pet supply business
store and I work for them I would sell
the wee-wee pads and they said you know
if we ever open a second store on Long
Island we would like you to orchestrate
so Fred starts texting me like two weeks
ago I gotta take Gary I've never read
your book I'm gonna read your book and
they're sending me all these texts about
heartfelt things in the book and then I
realize he's reading the book so he has
material to make fun of this
ammunition right it's called research
Gary puppet if you were guy if you
really got into the radio Hall affair
would you have an idea of what you would
say okay I will talk about my
Thanksgiving dinner oh yeah without
mother see we my mom would cook this
Thanksgiving dinner she would make the
you know the sweet potatoes with
marshmallows and the turkey and the
spaghetti and the meatballs but on a
side table looks like a little kids
table she had this little card table and
she would put the artichokes if anyone
deserves to be in the radio but you know
I want to nominate to the radio Hall is
that right there JD Harmon I'm not
kidding you
just to hear his speech but I mean
seriously you're good on the air I mean
you know I mean good bad you know what I
mean
golfer president in there I'm definitely
not afraid you're in my Hall of Fame
Fred would you be upset if Gary gets in
before you no no no Barry materi would
love that
oh you Carrie would be the guy it would
mean nothing to Fred but Scotty because
I'm bringing marrying Jackson because
I'm gonna bring Mary and you know dog
Baba because movie is my best friend
Bernie's dead oh oh I'm gonna drag him
in movie if you were here right now
you'd really enjoy this